this video is about two factor analysis
of variance with repeated measures
if we look at the most common types of
analysis of variance we distinguish
between one factor and two factor
analysis of variance and on the other
hand analysis of variance without
measurement repetition and with
measurement repetition this video is
about the two-factor analysis of
variance with measurement repetition
this brings us right to the first
question
what do i need two factor analysis of
variance with measurement repetition
four
two factorial analysis of variance with
measurement repetition
tests whether there is a difference
between
more than two samples divided between
two variables or factors
in contrast to the two factorial
analysis of variance without repeated
measures
one of the factors is created by
repeated measures so one factor results
from a dependent sample
but what is the difference to the normal
one factor analysis of variance with
repeated measures
the single factorial anova with repeated
measures
tests whether there are statistically
significant differences between three or
more dependent samples
now what is a dependent sample again
in a dependent sample the measured
values are connected thus
one and the same person is measured at
several points in time
if for example a sample of people
suffering from high blood pressure is
strong
and the blood pressure of these people
is measured before therapy
in the middle of therapy and at the end
of therapy
then this is a so-called dependent
sample
this is the case because one and the
same person was for example interviewed
at several points in time
so you might be interested to know if
therapy for high blood pressure has an
effect on blood pressure
therefore you would like to know if
blood pressure changes over time
but what if you have different therapies
and you want to check if there is a
difference between them now you have two
factors one's the therapy and once the
measurement repetition
since you have two factors and one of
the factors is a dependent sample you
use the two factor analysis of variance
with repeated measures
with the help of the two factorial
analysis of variance with measurement
repetition
you can now answer three things
first whether the first factor with the
measurement repetitions has an influence
on the dependent variable
then
whether the second factor has an
influence on a dependent variable and
finally you can also make a statement
whether there is a so-called interaction
effect between two factors
with that we can now move on to the
hypotheses
as already mentioned you can test three
statements with the two factorial
analysis of variance so there are also
three null hypotheses and therefore also
three alternative hypotheses
the first null hypothesis is
the mean values of the different
measurement times do not differ there
are no significant differences between
the groups of the first factor
then of course there is the second one
the means of the different groups of the
second factor do not differ
and the third null hypothesis reflects
the interaction effect
one factor has no effect on the effect
of the other factor
but what are the assumptions now well
the scale level of the dependent
variable should be metric for example
salary or blood pressure
the scale level of the factors should be
categorical
the measurements of one factor should be
dependent for example the measurements
should result from repeated measurements
of the same person the measurements of
the other factor should be independent
so the measurement of one group should
not be influenced by the measurement of
another group
the variances in each group should be
approximately equal and finally the last
requirement
the data within the group should be
normally distributed
now let's look at an example and i will
show you how to interpret the results
let's say this is our data that we want
to analyze each row is one person and
here we have the first factor with the
three time points before the therapy in
the middle and at the end of the therapy
and here is the second factor indicating
which therapy was used so is it therapy
a
b or c so in our example the first
patient received therapy a had a blood
pressure of 165
before the therapy in the middle a blood
pressure of
145 and at the end a blood pressure of
140. now let's first calculate the
example online with datadep and then we
will discuss how to interpret the
results
to calculate a two-factor analysis of
variance with repeated measures online
just visit datadept.net
and copy your own data into this table
then click on hypothesis testing under
this tab you will find a lot of
hypothesis tests and depending on which
variable you click on
you will get an appropriate hypothesis
test suggested
if you copy your data up here the
variables will appear down here
if the correct scale level is not
automatically detected you can simply
change it under variables view
for example if we click on before middle
and end
an analysis of variance with repeated
measures is automatically calculated
but we also want to include the therapy
so we just click on therapy
now we get a two-factor analysis of
variance with measurement repetition we
can read the three null and the three
alternative hypotheses here
and then we get the descriptive
statistics output
here we see the results of the analysis
of variance we'll look at these again in
detail in a moment
but if you don't know exactly how to
interpret the results you can also just
click on summary in words
but now back to the results
most important in this table are these
three rules with these three rows you
can check if the three null hypotheses
we formulated before are retained or
rejected the first row tests your null
hypothesis
whether blood pressure changes over time
so whether the therapies have an effect
on blood pressure the second row tests
whether there is a difference between
their respective therapy forms with
respect to blood pressure and the last
row checks if there is an interaction
between the two factors you can read the
p-value in each case right at the back
here
let's say we set the significance level
at five percent if our calculated
p-value is less than 0.05
then the respective null hypothesis
rejected and if the calculated p-value
is greater than 0.05
then the null hypothesis is retained
therefore we see here that the p-value
of before middle and and is less than
0.05 and thus the before middle and end
times are significantly different in
terms of blood pressure
the p-value in the second row is greater
than
0.05 therefore the types of therapy have
the same mean values over time it is
important to note that the mean value
over the three time points is considered
here it could also be that in one
therapy the blood pressure increases in
the other therapy the blood pressure
decreases but on average over the time
points the blood pressure is the same
then we would not get a significant
difference here if this was the case
however we would have an interaction
between the therapies and the time we
test this with the last hypothesis in
this case there is no significant
interaction effect between therapy and
time
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time